let's hear from the most important
people to the David packman show the
viewers and the listeners we like to
take calls via Discord you can join the
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord it's an incredible thing we are
going to start calls today how about
Tristan from Washington Tristan from
Washington welcome to the David packman
show what's on your mind today
hello David can you hear me yes I can
oh good Heavens to Betsy on a rich freck
right such an honor to start the show
today the honor is all mine sir
thank you so much so a couple things
um one I've called your show a few times
before and one of the last times you
called I was in Oregon I am now moved to
the Seattle area and we had discussed on
a previous call uh chocolate babka and I
am happy to report since I have moved
here I have found two different Jewish
delis in the area and I'm very happy I
hope that I can compare the two and give
back to you have you been to Seattle do
you know about any of these places no I
haven't but you know I follow very
closely uh J Kenji Lopez alt who does
now live in Seattle and he seems to post
some great uh food spots in Seattle the
food scene seems to be quite Lively
there
oh it's it's very Exquisite I I really
can't wait to try everything
um that it has to offer it's going to be
a great experience and I can't wait to
give you my report once I've experienced
The Culinary traditions of Seattle now
let me ask you one thing the chocolate
Bobcat that you've seen around there
they're not putting chocolate chips on
top are they
well I so I just moved here I haven't
gotten a chance to actually go okay down
there you know like I said last time the
only Bob guy I've tried was the Trader
Joe's and they do put chocolate chips on
there it's be very very suspicious about
uh chocolate chips on top of the babka
okay that's my advice but report back
when you know more
I will definitely do so can't wait to do
it
um next question sure um
I uh
so I'm a bit of a quirky guy I have
quirky beliefs and
I've been I want to take you back to the
founding of our country uh 222 years ago
when judicial review was was established
by the Supreme Court basically they gave
themselves that power and because the
Supreme Court has been in the news so
much I
and I realize this isn't actually going
to happen anytime soon but I just kind
of wanted to get your opinion do you
think
that overturning the president of
judicial review would actually solve a
lot of the problems that the court has
caused for us and following that do you
think what sort of system if you David
Pacman were the founding fathers of this
country what system of the for the court
do you think you would establish uh you
know I I don't on the second question I
don't know that's really more of a
question for a legal scholar I'm sure
you'll find all sorts of random
political people who will weigh in but I
really would leave that to Legal
Scholars the judicial review what what
you're talking about with judicial
review uh is essentially review by the
Supreme Court of the constitutionality
of legislative acts so it's sort of a
melding of what our legislative acts
carried out by the House and Senate and
the president and then comparing and
contrasting that with the Constitution
Constitution Bill of Rights and seeing
whether it is coherent with that and it
is sort of like an ultimate final word a
sense on the decisions that are made by
our legislators and there are people who
say well that's really a check and a
balance that's not actually appropriate
and it allows the Supreme Court to
become even political than than we
already know it's allowed to be I I
don't have a strong position as to
whether I would get rid of judicial
review what I'm more interested in is
I think that there are reforms that can
be made to the Supreme Court including
uh term limits and creating a
predetermined replacement schedule to
take out the politicization and strategy
around holding on for another year or
not I I there are other things that I
would like to change about the Supreme
Court which I've outlined in content on
the show previously which for me would
be lower hanging fruit than the the
judicial review question is really a
bigger one and I'd leave it to the
Constitutional law Scholars
okay I I completely understand and I
agree with you on that the only reason
that I bring it up is it seems like at
least to me in in the time that I've
spent on this Earth was just very short
um it seems like
we have sort of an ontological problem
in this country where we think that like
because something happened a long time
ago and it's been in place for a long
time that somehow it's better for it
well that's conservatism in a nutshell
you know yeah it definitely is and I've
been reading about the French republics
and the different you know
constitutional conventions that they've
had over the years since they founded
their first Constitution and I just it's
just so refreshing to hear about how
they've done it and and the maturity of
that country and and I just wish we
could do that here and so we wouldn't
have to have conversations like this
where it's like well is one big reform
that's not going to happen good or is a
small reform that also probably won't
happen is that a good thing you know no
I completely agree with you and I think
one of the biggest problems in even
having many serious political
conversations in the United States is a
huge contingent that says that just
because it's what was done in the 18th
century we should of course assume that
it's the right way to do things today
you have to break through that before we
can seriously talk about a lot of
different things but uh Tristan I
appreciate the call uh very uh important
elements uh questioned today
always great to hear from you David all
right there is Tristan from Washington
with a very powerful series of
declarations why don't we go next to is
it safe or safe from Detroit am I saying
that correctly
Saif
yes it's safe safe uh welcome to the
program
thank you thank you I should uh I just
wanted to ask about uh I don't know if
you read recently
I care about the israel-palestine
conflict and
whether the AC solution has even
possible at this point I just wanted to
I was wondering if you had any thoughts
about that I I did not see the article
you said the the article is about what
the acoustic solution and uh basically
how we have to start thinking about the
reality of the cell 1C solution at this
point oh I I have not seen that article
no I haven't seen it
um I'm a two-state solution guy and I
have probably 20 Clips on my YouTube
channel about it so I don't have really
any like new material about it but I did
not see that article
yeah okay and I guess I'm just wondering
um
hello
okay
safe disappeared by now all of us know
how creepy it is to talk to a friend
about something and then get ads that
are related when you use a free email
service from a big Tech Corporation your
emails are scanned even if you're
emailing your spouse or your doctor
which is why I recommend start mail the
email service that never scans or
analyzes your email our sponsor start
mail also lets you create unlimited
email address aliases so you don't even
have to give out your real email address
this protects you from spam and phishing
attacks phishing attacks are becoming
way more sophisticated with the rise of
chat GPT by the way start mail lets you
encrypt any email you send even if the
recipient isn't using encryption unlike
the big Tech email Services who store
even your deleted emails when you delete
an email in start mail it is gone
migrating from your current email
service to start mail is just a few
clicks so what are you waiting for stop
letting big Tech corporations spy on
your email my audience gets 50 off your
first year at startmail.com Pacman the
link is down below